I was born and raised in Sierra Leone a
small and very beautiful country in West
Africa a country reached both in
physical resources and creative talent
however Sierra Leone is infamous for a
decade-long libel war in the 90s when
entire villages were burnt down an
estimated 8,000 men women and children
had their arms and legs amputated during
this time as my family and I ran for
safety when I was about 12 from one of
those attacks I resolved that I will do
everything I could to ensure that my own
children will not go through the same
experiences we had the would in fact be
part of a Sierra Leone where war and
amputation we're no longer a strategy
for gaining power as I watched people
who I knew loved ones recover from this
devastation one thing that deeply
troubled me was that many of the
amputees in the country will not use
their prosthesis the reason I'll come to
find out was that their prosthetic
sockets were painful because they did
not fit well the prosthetic sockets is
the part in which the amputee in such
the residual limb and which connects to
the prosthetic ankle even in the
developed world it takes a period of
three weeks too often years for a
patient to get a comfortable socket if
ever prosthetic still use conventional
processes like molding and casting to
create single material prosthetic
sockets such sockets often leave
intolerable amounts of pressures on the
limbs of the patient leaving them with
pressure sores and blisters it does not
matter how powerful your prosthetic
ankle is
if your prosthetic socket is
uncomfortable you will not use your leg
and that is just simply unacceptable in
our age so indeed when I met professor
Hugh Herr about 2 1/2 years ago and he
asked me if I knew how to solve this
problem I said no not yet but I would
love to figure it out and so for my PhD
at the MIT Media Lab I design custom
prosthetic sockets quickly and cheaply
that are more comfortable than
conventional prosthesis I use magnetic
resonance imaging to capture the actual
shape of the patient's anatomy then use
finite element modeling to better
predict the internal stresses and
strains on the normal forces and then
create a prosthetic socket for
manufacturing we use a 3d printer to
create a multi material prosthetic
socket which relieves pressure where
needed
and the anatomy of the patient in short
we're using data to make novel sockets
quickly and cheaply in a recent trial we
just wrapped up at the Media Lab one of
our patients a u.s. veteran who's been
an amputee for about 20 years and won
dozens of legs said of one of our
printed parts it's so soft it's like
walking on pillows and it's effing sexy
disability in our age should not prevent
anyone from leaving meaningful lives my
hope and desire is that the tools and
processes we develop in our research
group can be used to bring highly
functional prosthesis to those who need
them for me a place to begin healing the
souls of those affected by war and
disease is by creating comfortable and
affordable interfaces for their bodies
whether it's in Sierra Leone or in
Boston
I hope this not only restores but indeed
transforms their sense of human
potential thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]